all right so we got you bro so basically
gc1 trying to get into gc2
thinks his positioning and wrote in
rotations is could use some work like
and subscribe exactly what's up mason
okay let's see what you can do better
danklin hey youtube how the you doing
agt jake here guys do this more do this
more right here right
how many of you guys would have jumped
at this ball raise your hand because i'm
even raising my hand i would have jumped
here this is so smart to just not let
this guy flail around and do nothing and
take possession that was nice
good stuff bro
now for the typical gc1
this is usually what happens right you
did something
gnarly here bro nice fake
let the guy go flying right past you
this is poggers bro very pogerwager
smile then what do you do
[ __ ] it up
this touch is really bad uh i know you
weren't trying to do that and you were
trying to keep possession but you just
kind of bopped it away from yourself so
like the typical gc1
you did a nice little play there but
then you
gave it right back to the other team so
hey
if you're gonna keep it if you're gonna
do something spicy to keep possession
you better keep it you know what i'm
saying so yeah exactly booted thanks for
the ball but you can have it back i'm
sorry i took it
i think you saw
brady is in their corner and you were
like nah nah bro
[Music]
i'm good i'm not gonna go yet i'm gonna
take my time
perfect great job this is perfect man
you're going you're trying to keep
possessions you know like all of that
was was very good
kind of saw this coming though man
so you were doing everything right
even here
i don't know why ninja brady is working
up so far right here bro
this is kind of more on ninja because he
leaks way too far up while you're
keeping pressure then he has to rotate
back really fast and then he
he panics
and he misses the net i'm not really
gonna say anything there i think that's
just unfortunate from your teammate
doing it because you were doing the
right stuff
if i have anything to say here like you
probably could have done a better job
keeping possession here
because that is just kind of hitting it
away from yourself
so this this is like
just a crappy situation that happened
where unfortunately you got scored on
you're not really doing anything that
bad
but
like even right here that's away from
your body
that's away from your body so like just
keep it close maybe go for the 50 50
could cut it right kyle but
every touch goes away from you here
whereas you just want to keep the ball
on top of you you know what i'm saying
that would have led to at least a 50 50
and not like a perfect hit
on your net type stuff you know what i'm
saying you could control it a little
better because you're making the right
decisions here
and all of that was good but you just it
wasn't on you and and it's weird because
90 of the time like those hits are
totally fine and your teammate isn't too
far up and it doesn't matter but if
we're thinking of something that would
be it i don't know about this one chief
let's look at this situation man so
brady ain't nowhere to be found
brady's way over here bro he don't want
anything to do with this i would say
that going for this boost over here when
this is happening is not the play if
your teammate was a little bit more
aggressive and probably should have been
going for that and i'm gonna guess ninja
brady was going for the corner boost
here let's see
oh look at that what literally everyone
does in this rank okay that screwed him
over here i don't even know if this
leads to a goal i have no idea it's
definitely not going to lead to a good
situation and that's what you're trying
to avoid in gc1 all the time is
situations where
your team is in a 1v1 and they kind of
mess it up doesn't lead to anything bad
the point
the reason i'm pointing it out is
because it could have led to something
really bad
okay
it didn't
not yet anyway but
definitely could have been doing
something different here i would say you
need to analyze the situation here
you're screwing your teammate over by
going for this boost
a hundred percent
i know you're getting boost and sava
doesn't get good possession of it and
then you gotta grow and you're rotating
back pretty quickly
but if sava was better
you're getting scored on right there
i'll tell you that right now so always
expect your
your opponent
to be god tier and play perfectly
and you'll likely find that they don't
99 of the time does that make sense
expect the worst from your team and the
best from the other team you're probably
gonna do pretty good you're you're
thinking about it though man i like it
you're you're uh i like your mindset
here you're playing quite well
you're trying to keep possession as much
as you can
you're doing it i like it man you have
the right mindset you're trying to keep
possession you're trying but your
execution's off right
i love like the mindset though you're
you're doing it you're trying but it's
not
it's not quite in your possession you
kind of eat it away from yourself a
little bit too much
and it's it's barely bro it's like
you're so close to like keeping
possession and flicking over people but
instead you're just in that spot where
it just goes right to them
so work on keeping it a bit closer
that's what i'm noticing right now how
many of you guys would have bursted at
this raise your hand if you would have
50 50 this ball 99 percent of people
would fly right at this ball
you shouldn't because your teammate is
out of the play if your teammate was
behind you sure you can go for this but
he's not so you decide to turn this is
perfect man
you are a good player like very smart i
like that
you see what you see what i mean here
though look at this so like
you've got it but you ex you missed the
execution this should be on your on top
of your car 100 right
but it's not so you're you have the
right idea you have the right mindset
the execution is just off you're messing
up a good amount mechanically with this
possession
so
you're gonna get so good so fast it's
crazy dude you're being let down by by
ninja here
what happened
he's just going for boost bro
it's not his fault bro
this is like tick-tock comments he's
just going for boost dude it's not his
fault dude this is why you don't go for
boost dummy
anyway
nothing you did there you could have
executed the possession in the flick
better
that's it ninja brady was completely out
of position there you should expect him
to be in the right spot
so basically the two goals that have
been scored against your team right now
are only because your teammates in the
wrong spot
and you could have kept better
possession
and had a better outcome
if we're thinking about what you could
do but you're really not doing anything
that bad here bro
yeah dude guys i don't know if you guys
saw that but i put it in discord where
one of my tick tock comments was
i just need more boost than everyone
else and i can't fast aerial so i need
more time and space and i
was cracking up it was so funny and
people were like dissing them like
replying and he he doubled down of
course and he's like what
that's fine i just play differently than
everyone it's most people are like yeah
you play back
you know this could have been better
better executed just like all the rest
of the plays here man to be totally
honest with you
gonna hit that a little bit more outward
i know you're trying to outplay the guy
in front of you you could have aerial
this with less boosts
probably waited a bit
before you aerial so you didn't have to
go straight up and waste all your boosts
and then right your team may f that up
completely dude that should be over
their net or internet i think the flip
here was a big big big mistake you know
just try and keep it on top of you
especially when you don't have boost
keep it close so you get 50 50 it
instead of just giving it to the other
team
i think we've said that like three four
times now so i think you get it there's
a lot of different things you could down
here besides tap it
to the right side of the wall you know
what i'm saying could have caught it
flicked it i think this is a bad
decision and i'm gonna say this again
it's just bad execution
even here again you got all the
opportunity because you have the right
mindset
to play
really good like this is ssl level
gameplay i'm watching or decision making
i'm watching right now just the
execution i would say is gc1
good positioning look at this chat
look at this this man has 23 boost and
where is he on the field
right smack dab where he's supposed to
right in the middle of the field waiting
for the pass he's not over here where
brady would be grabbing this boost okay
he's right here
big chillin
23 boost was plenty to shoot that ball
good job danklin
probably the literally the first bad
mistake i've seen
this is pretty
pretty bad because you're getting beat
to this ball a billion percent
so i think you just got bald here
mechanical error decision making error a
bit
but most of the game i haven't seen that
so that was just a good play by patzo
and a good demo
brady actually gets it sick
brady
oh no this is not what we want
nice
as good as you could do brady's gonna
center it for the other team again
and it it was all brought on by the fact
that you pushed a ball you shouldn't
have if we're going really far back you
know i'm saying
you gotta work on your execution when
you're controlling the ball and that's
all i saw
franklin really like you're you played
fantastic
but
your your mindset's really good your
your
the things you're going for are perfect
the execution is just off i would go
this this will make you so good so quick
if you're on pc which i'm assuming you
are dribble to overhaul and you do this
for like 30 minutes a day and you just
you try and plaster this ball to your
car like just close on your car just
don't give it away just keep it on top
of your car you are going to get good
quick if you can learn how to do this
really well you used to do this for
hours yeah same here like you'll
keep doing it
because right now that is your issue
it just pops off your car too often
that is all i've got for you dude other
than that you're
you're a rock star he's got to keep the
ball closer man that's all that's all i
got so hopefully that was helpful and if
you were watching
i hope it helped you in some way but
hey there you go bro
laughs in the chat for danklin
[Music]
poggers hoggers